because it was the question that got
posed to me yesterday we're going to
think about a deck of cards okay now
before I set you loose limit there's one
important thing that you need to see in
a question because at the moment this
question cannot be done by don't
binomial probability the way that we've
just done it okay there's something
missing okay think about it I told you
there were three different kinds of
things you needed to look for to know
when to use binomial probability is it
multistage yes okay
can you think of the question can you
phrase in terms of two outcomes in this
case you can clubs not clubs okay ah but
there are some words you're going to
need to look for to know that every
stage as you go along when you pick your
five cards they have to be identical
what words would you look for with
replacement if you do not see this
that's your beep flashing red sign to
say sorry tough luck you're just gonna
have to draw a probability tree okay but
when you see this it's like you're sort
of green ticket that you can just go to
this right so if you what you can draw
yourself a diagram though like I said
it's gonna get hard very fast okay I'll
leave this here so you can use this to
help me think as we said before we want
to break up an event into two different
outcomes and we already identified at
least in this set of questions you're
either going clubs or clubs right so the
probability of just a club for one of
those stages right is how many clubs are
there in a pack
13:52 or turn of the insane well there
are four students right so the
probability plot is a quarter which
means a probability of its complement is
3/4 okay so these are going to be our
building blocks right let's start off
part a if I want two clubs if I want to
be clubs then that probability is well
I've got I think about the number of
ways right this is how I start and I've
got five to choose from but I only want
two of them to be comes okay and so now
I think about what were the probability
of the stages be right well this is on
the club and I've got two of them so
it's square
right and then the other three remaining
cards will be not clubs think oh that's
it whatever that works out to be okay
puppy I'm gonna work out in exactly the
same way there are five to choose from
and I want one of them to be a club all
right so there are five ways to choose
just one club and you could you know
because this is a simple case you can
actually write that now look it to be
you know club and not club and him not
club called second you can write these
out quite easily just by pushing the
club dude okay just so you can get in
your head I see what's happening and
then you think about oh I'm gonna
multiply by the probability of getting
that one Club which is where ever it's
going to be it's just gonna be a quarter
and then I can't find him and when you
get to Potsie right when you see things
like this this is well it's as close as
it gets to a big red flasher you like to
say okay I don't want to think of all
the different ways there's a better way
think about this how can we approach it
it's a compliment isn't it
the probability of at least one what's
the only way to not get at least one
club you get no close right so this is
the probability this is the complement
of zero right so then how do I work this
out how'd it come from that's work again
so wait slow down before I get to the
numbers right in terms of probability
it's like this that's that's what the
compliment means for us okay that's an
important line for a marketer look for
okay so now I can go to numbers okay how
do I get no clubs well so the five to
choose from but I don't want any of them
right when I think about how many times
I need to consider this probability the
answer is no tires because I don't have
any of those and then the remainder no
the nut clubs okay now when you get to
the last one is kind of not really much
way to get around this okay a compliment
doesn't neatly divided it into something
that's hard to work out something easy
to work out you just got cases right so
how many different possibilities are
there for getting at least four clubs
there's two there's four clubs or five
funds right now I write it out like this
so that for me in my head it's clear
that I add these and I do not multiply
why do I add and not multiply because
because these can't possibly we have
been you simultaneously if you got nine
cards for burger you'd win every time
right so these are separate cases that's
why you add them yes and then of course
your work these out the same way that
you did before five shoes oh cool no
problem right so therefore you start to
get a feel for it now let's generalize
now when they talk about these they say
you know whatever event you know how we
divide it into two okay whichever event
you're interested in we call that a
success okay so here's the general case
if what you're interested in is some
number of successes took two successes
one success for all more successes okay
we call that number K how many successes
you're after the polity of getting K
successes out of well how many things
are here right this represents the
number of stages in our multistage event
right so you've got successes out of
four stages okay so in this case there
would have been five stages right well
there are going to be three components
three components first we're gonna work
out well how many arrangements are there
how many combinations are there that
will give me exactly K successes right
so you have
Jews okay right that's what it is every
time it was always fire to something
fight you something factory something
the idea a cheese can right and then you
got two pieces left what are the two
pieces how do we get them you got them
from I rubbed it off
you got them from whatever were the two
terms the two terms in your binomial
right so what they were one the
probability of success now that's for a
single one like like say a single club
how many of these do I need what powde I
need raised to it's okay cuz I'm gonna
have K successes right but then you have
to multiply by another probability what
would be a sensible thing to call that
you gotta call it not successful you can
call it failure I suppose probability
okay now how many of those are there how
many times does it fail well there n in
total and you take away all of the
successes of which there are K right so
this is our generalization for what
we've been doing here